you said something there that was very
interesting you said that she wanted to
be pestz and
worshiped um I think I think the key is
man is that she's a very pretty girl so
pretty girls growing up always will have
that they'll always have it they'll
always have a thousand guys wanting her
right and when you have that and you
have a guy like me that's like no I'm
like family unit I'm focused I want to
make money I want to build a build a
team around me I want to build all this
stuff I cannot put my I can do lots of
things but I cannot spend all my time on
one specific human I just can't it's
just it's not for me you know it is for
it's it could be for lots of guys and
there are lots of guys in that space
where they're happy just working their
ninet to5 or they're happy doing their
business I said that was interesting for
a reason though Mike because women they
tend to get bored of a guy that puts
them up on a pedestal for sure too much
too long too often and then they sort of
like get distracted by other things like
100% 100% you know there's an old saying
in England where I spent some time where
it was you've got to be a little bit
mean to keep them Keen right yeah and
yeah and I'm not saying you like be an
[__] but at the same time like I find
it very interesting when women say like
I want to be woried I want to be
idolized I want to be put up on a
pedestal and then when they get it and
that guy shows up they kind of look at
him like a beta mail and they're like
I'm not interested in this guy anymore
like I want the alpha that's like more
distracted by stuff for sure that's
that's bang on there's no there's no
doubt in my mind that's exactly what
happened you know I think that we get we
it's it's our Focus can't be on on on
another human all the time at some point
you difficult to manage that in a
long-term
relationship you make that commitment
you know you have the kid you know
you're at there chasing ACC since you're
giving her time and you're giving her
her interest but then they want more but
if you give them too much more than what
they want then they get bored they're
like ah this guy's giving me too much
attention like why can't he just be
doing something else why is he always on
my feet yeah for sure it's a weird
balance isn't it it's a weird balance
man and I mean listen man I think that
there's there's things I have to work on
I'm I mean even in my businesses on some
of my partnership I'm just way too nice
I mean I know this that I'm just way too
nice but I always tell my parents I'm
like it's worked for me and I feel like
you know what the more I give back it's
more effort there's more time because no
Partnerships 5050 so even same
relationships there's no relationship to
5050 I'm like I'm 100 I'm 100% getting
the money I'm 100% putting myself out
there you're 100% doing the work the
work at home you're 100% building some
deep love connect whatever the the
dynamic is between relationships no
nothing's 5050 everything something does
more than something it's just the the
doesn't really work it's all just yeah
made Bel stuff I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out